this is so funny how the tables have
turned remember when Chick-fil-A the uh
chicken fast food restaurant was the
darling of the right wing because it
took a an anti-gay stance and donations
to uh anti-lgbt organizations and
conservatives were flocking to the
drive-throughs and standing in line
outside Chick-fil-A because Chick-fil-A
supports traditional marriage and
so-called Christian values and the left
was boycotting Chick-fil-A because of
bigotry and discrimination times have
changed and I guess Chick-fil-A has also
changed Chick-fil-A has now come under
Fire from its former right-wing fans
because Chick-fil-A now has a statement
on its website about Dei as they like to
call it Dei stands for diversity
equity and inclusion and right Wingers
are now saying Chick-fil-A has succumbed
to the woke agenda there's a piece in
Newsweek Chick-fil-A faces a
conservative revolt for its Dei
initiative
the company website now said this is
like speaking of milk toast this is milk
toast one of our core values at
Chick-fil-A is we're better together
when we combine our unique backgrounds
and experiences with a culture of
belonging we can discover new ways to
strengthen the quality of care we
deliver to customers to the communities
we serve into the world we understand
that getting better at together means we
learn better care better grow better and
serve better
um okay
so listen there's a couple different
things here the irony is as delicious as
a spicy chicken sandwich with extra
pickles and grilled jalapenos
the same people who accused liberals of
being intolerant cancel culture
supporting lunatics
are now themselves calling for a boycott
of Chick-fil-A
because Chick-fil-A is now being
inclusive and respectful the same people
who previously defended Chick-fil-A's
right to express its religious beliefs
which happen to be Christian those
people are now outraged that Chick-fil-A
is trying to live up to its mission of
glorifying God by being a good steward
by having this Dei inclusivity statement
and it seems to me that some of these
conservatives must think that to be
faithful to God you shouldn't be
inclusive and want equity and want
diversity seems to me that that is quite
Godly isn't it they think oh Chick-fil-A
wants to have a positive influence I
guess that means we need to boycott them
now Chick-fil-A is not perfect I have
not done a u-turn on Chick-fil-A I've
still never been to a Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A is a big corporation that is
calculating what is best for them right
now they have done some to try to repair
the damage they did in terms of their
relationship with the LGBT community
based on what happened a couple of years
ago they have a Dei statement let's see
if they prove that it's not just lip
service let's see if they actually are
committed to some kind of change as a
result of this but it is also not the
enemy of the right wing this is a
business adapting to Changing Times
trying to meet the needs and
expectations of its customers its
employees and its would-be customers I
was think
of trying Chick-fil-A this weekend with
all of this hubbub I've never been I'm
going to be out on Long Island for a
conference this weekend and I thought
there's a bunch of Chick-fil-As there
but then I looked at the menu
it's pretty nuts like I don't wanna you
know I I'm all for I'll try all sorts of
different things but I looked at the the
menu
um and you know the rib meat with water
injected into it and formed into a Patty
and then breaded and deep fried like I I
just don't know that I want that you
know so it's it's pretty Bonker stuff
but you know maybe I'll show up and get
like a grilled chicken and report back
how it is in the meantime Marjorie
Taylor green and her boyfriend on their
latest podcast commented about
Chick-fil-A and they wrongly claimed
that the left was boycotting Chick-fil-A
because Chick-fil-A would close on
Sunday which is of course very much not
true so I don't see the left having any
buying power
at all in the marketplace I think that's
a great analogy uh you brought up
Chick-fil-A a lot of us have forgotten
about Chick-fil-A being being boycotted
and targeted so heavily like they did on
the left uh people were mad at them
simply because they they closed their
doors on Sundays uh because the owners
of Chick-fil-A are Christians and they
believe in taking a day of rest uh like
Bible talks about like God says you
should rest one day a week and that's
what the owners of Chick-fil-A decided
that's the way they're going to run
their company and they don't apologize
for it and the left targeted them
because they're Christians and yeah and
their stance on marriage ah there
so even Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend having to say Well it did have
some their stance on marriage it did
also actually have to do with their
support of anti-lgbt causes it wasn't
just being closed on Sunday many
businesses are closed on Sunday many
Jewish delis are closed to during
Shabbat that's being closed on certain
days for religious observance is very
different than than donating to anti-gay
causes so maybe I'll go to Chick-fil-A
this weekend I guess I'll go grilled
rather than fried that that um the rib
meat with the water injected into it I'm
just not big on that I have to admit
it's just it doesn't sound great to me
but I will report back if I end up at a
Chick-fil-A